- All right y'all I'm still here
keeping up with my social distancing
with my family here in Montana.
This hour though we're
gonna be celebrating
my new single I Dare You
that I actually got to record
in six different languages
which was really a dream come true for me.
The song is about love in all its forms
in the face of adversity,
choosing to love instead of fear.
I'm proud that there's singers
from all over the world
sang with me on this track.
I love all the different languages,
I actually listen to those
more than the English version.
But we're singing in
their native languages,
and we're still excited that
we actually have them on Zoom today.
We have Blass from Espana,
we have Nifuzia from Morocco,
we have Carolyn from Germany,
and we also have Mya from Israel,
how y'all doing?